[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
My name is [INAUDIBLE],, and
I'm excited to introduce
the speakers today.
As enterprises ramp
up their API programs,
IT teams are looking for
ways to abstract away
the complexities
of developing API
and speed up the
development process.
One of the
opportunities to do that
is using cutting-edge
cloud services
to abstract away
the complexities
and add to your API.
Today we're going to be focusing
on one of those services,
specifically the data loss
prevention service in order
to ensure the
security of your API
by abstracting away the
complexities related
to identifying and
masking sensitive data.
Speakers today are
Prithpal Bhogill,
who is the product manager on
Google Cloud's Apigee team,
and Scott Ellis, who's
the product manager
for a Cloud with the LP.
Prithpal, take it away.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: OK.
Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Super excited to be here.
Again, welcome.
So let's talk a
little bit about what
are our customers doing today.
When we talked to several
of them, many of them
are at some point of time in
their digital transformation
journey.
And, essentially,
what that means
is a lot of the
enterprise digital assets
that they have that could be
hidden in some backup systems,
databases, even new
cloud native applications
that they're building,
but many of them
need to be able to convert
into API for delivery
connected experiences,
which is the hallmark
of any kind of digital
transformation effort.
So what that means is because
they're building so many APIs
and they're
innovating, they also
need to be able to build
these APIs fast and much more
securely.
As we start to
dissect what customers
are doing from their
APIs, the moves to Cloud
have become very
real, and they're
leveraging more and more
services within their APIs.
And so today we're going
to look at how customers
can use Apigee Edge to be
able to accelerate the API
development while using some
of these cloud services.
So let's just break down--
how does one access
cloud service?
If you look at any
cloud service out there,
we believe it has
four high level steps.
So one of the very first
things you have to do
is first determine
what my credentials are
to a specific cloud service.
Next, then I need to
be able to figure out
how I manage for instance
all those credentials.
And, of course, to an
end point, which is you
need access to all that I can
use to access this service.
Step 3, then I have to
actually store and manage
the access [INAUDIBLE].
And then finally in step
4, once I have that token
I would then use
that to actually call
the original [INAUDIBLE]
that are really intended to.
As a developer, I have to really
take on a lot of complexity.
And if I'm doing this
thing for one API,
just imagine that I would be
doing this thing for the 10
APIs that I'm building.
Well, it turns out many of these
things don't work out very well
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm doing a [INAUDIBLE]
of steps again and again.
It takes a lot of time
for [INAUDIBLE] steps.
And last but not the
least, administrators
are never happy about letting a
developer work on credentials.
They want clean
separation of controls
where they are working with
[INAUDIBLE] and credentials,
and developers are really using
some of those capabilities.
So how can we really simplify
the experience for a developer,
yet make it easy for them
to consume these services
at a very fast pace?
So today we're
going to be talking
about a feature of Apigee Edge.
So Apigee's a full
lifecycle API platform ,
and it has all the bells and
whistles to be able to offer
API security.
You can have out-of-the-box
policies to do things like
traffic management,
transformation.
And you can power an
entire API program
whether you're starting
small or as a big enterprise,
whether you want to reach
the level of monitoring APIs.
It has all those
core capabilities
built into the platform, along
with end-to-end analytics
and monitoring.
But API extensions
is a new feature,
which was introduced last year.
And we built a series
of new extensions
that we recently released
at the Google Cloud Next.
These extensions are nothing
but package offerings
to be able to easily connect to
some of these cloud services.
And it makes it easy for
application developers
as they are leveraging more and
more of these cloud services.
Instead of interacting with them
using the four steps that we
spoke about a full Apigee
into an extensible platform,
and you can pretty much just
use any policies out there.
What we saw over time is this
specific [INAUDIBLE] experience
at Cloud Service is something
we need to be repeatable.
It's something we
also need to be
usable within the enterprise.
But as the adoption of those
services is on the rise,
developers want to build
API [INAUDIBLE] much faster.
So what I would like to
do at this point in time
is actually talk about a very
high level use case scenario.
I will do one
quick demo which is
focused on what Apigee Edge
is and how we can quickly
build an API.
But we have a two-part series.
And after this demo,
we will actually
talk about what [INAUDIBLE]
value does, [INAUDIBLE]
prevention does, and how it
can really help enterprises
secure sensitive data.
But this point in time, I'm
going to share my screen.
So what you're seeing here is
the Apigee Edge user interface.
So in this scenario, imagine
I'm an API developer,
and I want to very quickly
build an employee API.
And I want to be able to
connect and get some data out
of BigQuery as an example.
And that's an
employee data center,
and I want to be able to
easily access that data.
So one of the first things
you do in the Apigee platform
is you go and build this thing
that we call it an API proxy.
An API proxy does very, very
basic control construct.
As an API developer,
I can go and click
on the plus proxy
icon, and I can
choose a variety of
different flavors,
whether I'm using just a simple
reverse proxy and point, which
is one of the most
common use cases
or whether I'm
converting SOAP to Rest.
You can also use
Node.js as an example
to build out an API proxy.
So you can go
through these steps
and actually go and build
[INAUDIBLE] on the API.
But what I'm going to
do as part of this demo
is going to show
you an existing API.
Call is going to be API.
So right now I'm in the old
view definition for the API.
So you can see what
different kind of endpoints
it exploded out here.
And if I hovered over
to the develop tab, what
I see out here is what we
call as the API proxy editor.
So I'm going to really
quickly switch on
to revision two,
which is the one I
want us to look at right now.
So just walking through this
API proxy really quickly
and you see one of the
very first things that
happens when an API call is
made, they just verify the API
key just to make sure that
a legitimate request is
the requester is
calling the API.
Within the API
editor, I can actually
choose from a variety of
different kinds of policies
for traffic management,
put out spike arrest.
That's if you want
to use caching.
You need a bunch of different
kind of security policies
to secure the API and then
a bunch of mediation policy
if you want to do
transformations,
so on and so forth.
And the platform by
itself is extensible.
So I can use any of
these capabilities
write some code snippets, and I
can really extend the platform
to the way I want it.
In this scenario, there's
a list-employees flow
which actually uses a capability
called Apigee extension.
I'll just get back
to that capability
in just a couple of minutes.
But that's something I'm getting
at about from the BigQuery data
set, and I want to be able
to return the data set.
So let's just take a very
quick peek at how may
I actually run this API
and get some data back.
OK I'm going to switch
to an arrest line,
in this case, postman.
And out here, you can see that
I am on the list employees
matter.
If I hit a send request out
here what's really happening
is if I could be making
a call to the Apigee
API in the backend,
and this trace tool
will actually tell you about
the request had been processed.
You can see that it's
called the Verified API
Key, which ensured that every
request which is coming in
is secure.
It made a call to query,
and it got some data back
and is returning to
employee data set back.
So if I go back
to my rest line, I
can see that I
got the data back.
So this is a very
basic, simple step one.
So that maybe take
a peek through this
and figure out how did we really
achieve this thing, and what
will be the speed part of
building your API faster
by using some cloud services.
So for now what I'm
going to do is quickly
go on to an area
within the Apigee Edge
UI known as extension.
So this is where we
have a lot of extensions
that they've already
prepared for our customers.
So you come into
the Extensions tab,
and this is a classical
activity that the administrator
of this Apigee Edge board
would be performing.
So you come out here and
you would add an extension,
and you can see we have several
extensions to various Google
Cloud Services,
including the one
that we will be
showcasing today,
the Google Cloud Data
Loss Prevention extension.
So as you start to
look at an extension,
you can give it a
name and description.
And you can see the
variety of different kinds
of other extensions
we have, including
extensions to a bunch of other
kinds of services as well.
So we'll go back to the
general prevention API.
If I go back to extensions,
it should pull up
a list of all the
different extensions
that I already have configured.
Let me add the
word VLP out here.
I can search this
specific extension
instance which is considered.
At this point in time, you
can see that I can go to here,
add the [? GDP ?] [INAUDIBLE],,
which is the one that you are
using the [INAUDIBLE]
baby from, add
some kind of basic
information types in here,
and then add microseconds.
That's how you would end up
configuring a simple extension.
In this case, this shows you
how a [INAUDIBLE] extension
looks like.
The administrators
really like this
because now they're the ones who
are configuring the extensions
[INAUDIBLE] credentials.
And they can get
access to [INAUDIBLE]
how is this extension,
in general working.
Right?
They are [INAUDIBLE]
in doing this.
And if you now flip over back
to the API proxy out here,
we'll go back right into
the employee's API proxy.
And in that you
will actually notice
that we have used in the
list employees flow that
is something that
we just invoked
the use of BigQuery extension.
So the regular ID
extension is pretty simple.
You actually use the
extension [INAUDIBLE] policy,
and you pick the
specific extension
that has been deployed for you.
In this case, it is a
BigQuery employee's extension.
And we'd walk into the
[INAUDIBLE] extension
of the second demo
here, as well.
But now this extension
makes all the methods
that are available in
the BigQuery API, just
a simple call that
a developer can do.
And once the developer
uses the extension,
all they have to do here
is consider the data set
and the table that
they are after
and the platform
manages the rest.
They don't have to
worry about credentials.
They don't have to do any kind
of maintenance and management
of access tokens.
The developer interface
is very simple.
And this really
takes API development
at a higher level
in terms of making
it super easy to consume
the APIs and cloud services
and build your APIs faster.
So what I'm going to do
at this point in time
is I'm going to stop
my screen share.
And at this point in time, we're
going to switch focus slightly.
So now we will get a little
bit into what the data loss
prevention extension
is all about.
We'll have Scott now touch on
how does the demo prevention
service, to begin with, offer
this kind of protection,
where different options are.
And once Scott is done, we
will come back to Apigee the
and show you how you can easily
[INAUDIBLE] the data loss
prevention service and secure
sensitive data within an API.
With that, Scott.
SCOTT ELLIS: Great.
Thanks, Prithpal.
And I think you showed how the
Apigee extensions can really
make it easy for
administrators and developers
to both deploy APIs and
have that enterprise grade
control over your API.
So we're going to talk about
how the DLP Extension can give
the same admins and developers
a level of data protection
across other APIs.
But before we do that,
let's talk a little bit
deeper on what our Cloud
DLP can actually provide.
So what we're going
to do is, first,
let's just kind of
dive in a little bit
and understand what sensitive
data is and the kind of things
that we're going
to protect against.
So just some basic
examples of sensitive data.
If you heard things like
personal identifiable
information, or PII,
it might be related
to financial data,
health data, and it could
come from a variety of sources.
It could come from your users.
It could come about
your employees,
or it could also be
something that is
shared between your partners.
And, so, sensitive data can
enter into your enterprise
in a lot of different ways.
And as you're
building your APIs,
since you're interacting
with all of these sources,
we want to show you how you
can protect and understand
where this sensitive
data is slowing
throughout your enterprise.
And really the goal that
you have when you're
dealing with sensitive data--
we kind of summarized
into two goals here.
One is you want to use
that data properly,
and you want to
minimize exposure.
You can relate this to some
concepts around least privilege
or need to know,
but the basic idea
is if you don't need a bit of
sensitive data to do something,
then you don't want
to collect that
or you don't want
to expose that.
The second part here is
how do you be accountable?
And the key thing
here is you can
have a policy that says
how to use data properly,
but you really also want to
be able to demonstrate that.
And so will you be accountable
from an audit perspective
or just from a best
practices perspective.
And so, really, these controls
will help you do both of these.
So how can Cloud Data
Loss Prevention help?
What Cloud Data Loss
Prevention brings
is the ability to
discover and classify
sensitive data, as well as
de-identify or mask that data.
And so out of the box when
we talk about discovery
and classification what
we're talking about
is the ability to go in and
look for things like credit card
numbers, social security
numbers, different types of PII
that maybe you've
had global types that
could be country specific.
And so out of the box our
Cloud DLP Infrastructure
has about 90
built-in classifiers.
And then you can go in
and create your own custom
classifiers or augment
the ones that we have.
Once you find the data, the
next thing you might want to do
is actually go in and figure
out how to secure the data.
And this is a process known
as de-identification or data
masking.
And so the idea here is, let's
say you find a credit card
number in a particular set of
text or a request a response
coming into your API.
You want to actually potentially
go in and either just redact
that out or mask it somehow.
The animation that
we're showing here
is showing a little
bit of a before
and after on some
structured data.
And we're just showing
the application
of a variety of
different techniques
here, things like
format-preserving encryption
where we can actually
take an identifier
and produce another identifier
that obscures the data
but still keeps a lot of the
integrity of the original data,
as well as doing
different types of masking
or partial masking.
In that last, column
the Comment field,
we're showing something
very powerful here.
We're actually combining our
inspection and our masking
together to actually
go into the text here.
And if you notice in
the Comment field,
we're going in and
looking for sensitive data
and only masking that
part of the Comment deal
that has a sensitive data.
And that's something that
we'll show an example here
to an API scenario.
So how can this help you with
your production workload?
So let's look at a
example scenario.
Let's say that you have
a customer support chat
application and in
that chat application
you have a customer
and a support agent
just communicating
back and forth.
And in the context of that
chat the customer decides
to overshare, they decide
to give more information
than you actually need.
So in this case, we are
looking for the last four
digits of their social to
validate their account.
But the customer gave their
full social, their phone number,
their email address, just
gave a lot more information
than the support agent wanted.
And we may not want to
collect that information.
We may not even want to
show it to the agent.
So by using our inspection
and masking tools
we can actually go in and
mask that data in real time,
either before the agent
saw it or before we
persisted to this, depending
on what you want to do there.
And so this is a very
high-level scenario here.
And next we're going
to go in and show
a little bit deeper examples
of how this might work on APIs.
So, really, with
Apigee and Cloud DLP,
how can we give your
enterprise that data protection
across your API?
So admins can apply this
from an admin perspective,
or developers can
take advantage of it
as easy as how Prithpal
showed earlier.
Just applying an extension
and deploying this.
Let's walk through
a couple examples.
So, first, imagine how
your enterprise is working.
You've got clients at
the top here coming
from a variety of
different sources.
Behind the scenes,
you've got all
of your actual services,
your stores, everything
going on there.
And the arrows represent
various interactions
between your backend
systems and your clients.
And what we just want
to highlight here
is this red arrow.
Let's say it contained
sensitive data,
and it's some sort of sensitive
data going out to someone
on the web, a user on the web.
It could be a potential
data exposure.
And so, again,
sensitive data going out
would be something where you
might be revealing something
from an internal system
and exposing it externally.
Whereas something coming in on
a request, the second red arrow
here, where maybe a partner is
sending information to your API
that you don't
intend to collect.
Maybe it has sensitive
data in there
that you don't want to log,
or you don't want to collect.
And that could be an example
of a potential inadvertent data
collection.
And so when you think of
things like data minimization
and least privilege
and need to know,
you really want to look at how
can I produce these exposures,
as well as reduce collecting
information that we don't need.
And that's where the Apigee
API Platform with the Edge
extension and Cloud
DLP can really
help you inspect and mask
across all of your APIs.
So with the arrows now
that are showing in green,
we're basically saying, we
can actually apply that policy
so that you are only
exposing and collecting
the information
that you intend to.
Just walk through just a
high-level example of these.
So let's say that you
have an order API.
In this order API, the
intent is that the requester
is going to send in an
order ID, and then you're
going to respond back with a
status, maybe a transaction
amount.
But in this example that's
highlighted in the red box,
we have a user of the API decide
they're going to also include
an email address and
a raw credit card
number in the request.
Now, this isn't something you
need to process the request,
but it may be something that you
just accept and end up logging
because you logged the
request that came in.
And even though you don't
need or use that information,
you really don't want to log it.
And you shouldn't be collecting
it because that's not
the purpose of this API.
So when we talk about
inspecting and then
applying DLP across our API,
what we're really saying
is you don't want
this information.
And with DLP, we can go in and
do something like masking it.
So now when this request comes
in, the order ID is preserved,
but the email address
and the card number
are just automatically
masked out
of the request parameter
because you didn't need them.
So now when you log
this information,
you're still going
to see that this
as partner or this requester
sent that information.
You're just not logging the
actual raw sensitive PII.
You were showing
the redaction there,
but you really have the
full power of our Cloud DLP
infrastructure.
So it may be that you want
to collect that information.
You don't want to
just redact it,
but you want to do something
even more powerful.
So let's look at that
similar example here.
But instead of just simply
redacting the information,
because you have the full
power of the tokenization
and masking, you
could actually go in
and use tokenization
methods to obscure that data
but still keep the integrity.
And what we mean here
is that that long token
that you see there for the email
address and the credit card
number keep integrity because
if multiple requests are coming
in with the same email or
credit card number being sent,
you actually can still join
and match on that information.
You keep the integrity
there, but your APIs
not logging or collecting
or preserving that raw PII.
You're using a token instead.
So that's a very powerful
thing that you can do,
which is as simple as changing
the configuration on the DLP
side.
So now let's just look
at a similar example,
but in reverse.
Let's look at a
potential data exposure.
So let's look at
that same order API.
Someone sent in an order
ID, and your intent
is that you want to share out
the amount and the status.
Maybe this is a product
that's being ordered,
and you want to show here
that it's been shipped.
But you also have a note
field that you exposed.
Maybe that note has some
very important information
that you want to share
with the requester.
In this example, we've
shown that the note actually
contained, in the Comment
field, a credit card number,
and you did not
intend to expose that.
So by applying that
same policy that we
saw before, but on the
outbound, on the responses
here, again, that
sensitive data we
can mask in line so that
the requester still gets
the amount, still gets
the status of shipped,
still technically gets the note.
But that sensitive information
has now been redacted
or if you chose you could
tokenize it as well.
So this is just
showing how we can
help prevent a
potential data exposure
by inspecting and masking
that data on the response.
Great.
And with that we're going
to pass it back to Prithpal
to go to a more in-depth demo.
We're going to show
again how we can combine
the power of our enterprise
data protection controls
with DLP with the
enterprise admin
and developer controls for
the Apigee and Apigee Edge
extensions.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL:
Excellent Thanks, Scott.
So that was a great
summary of how
you can measure the
data protection service
and be able to have different
layers of protection
in the enterprise.
I think you did a good
job in highlighting
in an [INAUDIBLE] API
example, where the credit card
information needs
to be protected.
Maybe that was something
which was a mistake or error
but the developer
didn't really notice.
So let's now bring it
back to the same employee
example of here.
In this case, what I'm
going to do out here
is I'm going actually
switch over to revision 3.
So one of the first things
I'm going to do out here
is now let's start to bring
in the power of the data loss
prevention API and using the DLP
extension that Apigee Edge has.
So in the previous demo I
showcased how you can easily
configure an extension.
I walked you through how the
BigQuery extension was used.
So in this case
what we're doing is
limiting the results
that are coming back
to just one employee.
But we now show
that you know how
to use this particular
to DLP extension
and how to protect
sensitive data.
So I'll walk you through the
Apigee Edge experience first.
One you've done Apigee
Edge and use a feature
called Shared Flows.
So what's a Shared Flow?
Imagine you're an API developer
and you're using an API proxy
and using a bunch of different
policies in the proxy.
But [INAUDIBLE] new API.
They're a consistent set of
policies that you may use
[INAUDIBLE].
So we have something
exactly for that.
I just switch over to this
Shared Flow office down here,
and you can see that you
have a Shared Flow that
says protect with DLP.
And so this Shared Flow again,
as you saw in the API proxy
editor, contains what we call as
a bunch of different policies.
So all the policies that
you saw there, many of them
can be added out here
to a Shared Flow.
And so the Shared Flow becomes
the common shared execution
unit, if you would.
So in this case,
in the Shared Flow
I've added a few
different policies.
First of them is to extract
the payroll that comes out,
and I only want to be
with the [INAUDIBLE] that
could come back.
And then I'm going to
apply a specific template.
So if you look at the
data set out here,
and the input that I'm
sending in, I'm saying, great.
Whatever data is coming back
from BigQuery, aka [INAUDIBLE]
data, I want to be
able to take and pass
in the different elements
of the [INAUDIBLE] here.
And I want to specifically
apply one of the DLP templates.
In this case, we
call it test DEID 1.
So [? that ?] in fact
is request the DLP,
the DLP service will take
the specific template,
apply that on the payroll
that is passing in,
and you will see that
it automatically takes
and protects the sensitive data.
In this case, the
employee PII data.
SCOTT ELLIS: Right.
And I need you to
mention here what's
really powerful about that
is it is by applying this
at the policy level,
what that really
means is you get that
protection across the board.
This is something that let's
say again as your code changes,
as the developers go in,
and then say add new fields
or change your code,
they don't have
to worry about that policy.
That policy is applied
across the board.
So that way if a new
field is introduced,
if that field is something
that goes against the policy,
it will just automatically
get picked up at that layer.
They don't have to think about
deploying that policy one off
in their development cycle.
They just get that across the
board as more of a gray area--
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: [INAUDIBLE]
SCOTT ELLIS: That's a great way.
And, really, when you think
of protecting sensitive data,
a lot of these
cases are somewhere
where something
inadvertently gets out
or a field is
added to a response
that someone didn't realize
contained sensitive data, so
this administrative policy
and applying those DLP
templates really gives you
that added layer of protection
and accountability where you can
show that, regardless of what's
happening on that
development side,
we have this consistent
enterprise great control going
across our APIs.
I think that's just
super powerful.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: I agree.
So maybe just talk
maybe for a minute on--
Let's just take a
peek at this template.
Maybe you can walk us through
your first template here.
So this is the one
template that we're talking
about called Test EID one.
SCOTT ELLIS: Yes so
what we're showing here
is we're going to show
this Test EID one template.
It's a very, very simple
but powerful template.
And what we're showing here
is actually just the JSON
representation of the template.
The top part just has some
of the metadata about what
the template is, when
was it created or edited,
which can be important
just to understand
when it was last updated.
But the main thing
we're doing here
is we're basically saying,
if you find something that's
part of our inspection
policy, simply replace it
with the type.
So we have a
built-in setting here
that says whatever you find take
it out and put it in the type.
So if it was a
credit card number,
you're just gonna get the
word, credit card number,
in brackets.
If it was an email
address, you'd
get email address in brackets.
So what that does is it
gives you an across the board
layer of protection that
still gives you some insight.
If you're doing
debugging or you're
going and actually
looking at, let's say,
a detail of what
data was collected,
you're going to get
that insight of what
happened to what was collected
here, what was detected.
But you're not going to
get the raw PII stored
or flowing through your system.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: OK, perfect.
So let's actually take a
look at this in real life.
So coming back to this,
here's our shared flow,
so I'll go back to my API proxy.
And once I go back
out here I'll ring up
the employee's API proxy which
is what you are looking at.
And I'll go and
point of revision 3.
Let's make sure we
deploy revision 3 here.
So revision 3 is the one were
I'm actually working the shared
flow.
So, as Scott just
spoke about it,
one of the key things of
the shared flow feature
is it's a usable set of policies
that can [INAUDIBLE] every API
proxy.
Right.
But within that if you're
using the DLP template one.
So what we're really
doing out here
is once the data goes as
part of a request coming in,
we do some basic checks.
And both systems going through
the [INAUDIBLE] of that
from BigQuery.
We track only one
record from there.
And then on the return,
the response side of it,
we involve the shared
flow [INAUDIBLE]
actually uses that
template and applies to it.
So I'm going to put this thing
back into trace mode here
and I'm going to go
back to my rest line.
And this is the data set
that you were seeing earlier.
And now let's see once
you apply the template
one, what happens
to the data set.
Assuming the demo
board was still with us
and this comes through, what
should typically happen out
here is it goes back to the
backend, applies the template,
and now takes the
first record data set.
and involves the DLP template.
So in this case,
as you mentioned,
instead of [INAUDIBLE]
information,
it successfully de-identified
the email address and other PII
information from the payload
without having the developer
need to do anything special.
The template took care of this.
SCOTT ELLIS: Correct Yeah, and
all of this was configurable.
What you looked
for like specifying
that you care about email
address, location, and phone
number in this example,
as well as what
we saw in that template, what
do you do when you find it.
So in that template again in
a very simple configuration we
simply said,
regardless of what type
was found to be
inspected for, I simply
want to replace the type.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: OK, excellent.
Now let's take this
up another notch.
Right?
So we did one template.
You also spoke about
another kind of template.
Maybe I think one of the
things you've expressed earlier
is maybe people don't
want to be identified
or that maybe use some
kind of a hashing method
to be able to protect any
kind of information leaking.
Can you talk a little
bit about that template?
SCOTT ELLIS: Sure.
And so what we're
showing here is
an extension of that previous
template that we saw.
So you'll notice the very first
transformation is filled out
replaced with type.
And we're applying that
as sort of a catchall.
So, again, we inspect for
a certain amount of things.
If we find it, we're going
to replace with type.
But you'll notice right below
we've added onto that to say,
but if it's an email address we
want to do something different.
So in this example,
what we've done
is a simple one-way crypto-based
hash, Where we said,
when that email address
comes in, we want to take it,
apply cryptoHash, a secure
hash, that will give us
that consistent integrity.
So every time that same
email address comes in,
we're going to
see the same hash.
And that's going to let us
do some additional analytics
or capture information here
about that email address
that we may need as opposed
to simply replacing it
with the word.
Now in this example, we're
using a simple one-way hash
with an unwrapped
key, but I wanted
to explain a little bit
of the flexibility here.
We have a lot of other methods.
We have two-way way methods.
So we have tokenization
methods that
can be, basically, where
you can create a token
then you can reverse that token
as long as you have the key.
We also have methods
that allow you
to do that with a
format-preserving encryption.
Using a format-preserving
encryption method
that will provide some
additional integrity
for character set and length
of the thing you're collecting.
So for example, if you have
a 16-digit credit card number
and you want the output
to be a 16-digit number,
the format-preserving encryption
method can help you do that.
There's a lot of power there.
The next part is when
you look at the key.
So normally when you're going
to deploy this in a production
environment what you would do
is you would use our integration
with our Cloud Key
Management system,
or KMS, to wrap that key so
that it's protected here.
The key is not going to
be stored in the clear.
But it's also going to give you
that extra layer of protection
from an audit or an
access control perspective
that the key also has to be
accessible by the platform.
So you get again additional
enterprise great control
and audit whenever
you're doing one
of these crypto tokenization
or tokenization methods.
So this template,
again, even though it's
just about five or six
lines in this JSON file
that we've added, we've now done
something extremely powerful.
We've added the ability
to do a full tokenization
of those email addresses, so
that we get rich value out
of that data while also
protecting everything
else that we found with the
simple redact and replace.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: OK.
So now let's take this back
to the same employee example
and apply this new template
and see how the output differs
from what we had earlier.
Again, as you
mentioned, this could
be this classical scenario
of the enterprise deciding
to not change the
policy and apply
just another different kind of
mechanism and, in this case,
a hashing algorithm.
But, again, the extension
makes it super easy
for you to consume that.
So at this point
in time, I'm going
to revision four which is now
going to actually reference
this template number two
which Scott just spoke about,
another style of showcasing
how you can protect data.
So what I've done at
this point in time
is I have considered
the API proxy
of the use the second
extension, which
is the extension of type 2.
And I'm going back
to the [INAUDIBLE]
and run this report.
Does this API call
one more time?
And if everything
works fine, you
should notice that,
instead of me identifying
that email address
in particular,
we are actually able to just
use the hash specification
because I mentioned in
the specific complaint.
SCOTT ELLIS: Yes,
and so what you
see here is now that
response going back out,
the requester of this API
is now getting that hash
for that email address.
So let's just say,
for example, that they
are doing some
analytics and having
that hash for that
email address would
allow them to again do those
analytics based on the hash.
But they would not know what
the original email address is.
So, again, you're still
obscuring and protecting
the data, but you're
allowing them now
to see that consistency
after multiple responses are
coming back at the
same hash, even
though it's the same email.
And that's just the key
balance when we're looking at.
Protecting the data, but
also minimizing the exposure
while also allowing
that business process,
that analytics, to still happen.
And that's a key balance
that we're trying to strike.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: --and I
think you make a great point
because administrators
not only want
to know that, hey, we don't
want any sensitive data to leave
the enterprise [INAUDIBLE]
as both inbound or outbound.
And you can use the
extension in that capacity,
either to the request coming in
or even when you send data out.
But, more importantly, if
I was to double up on this,
you could take the Apigee
Edge and [INAUDIBLE] features,
right, which is [INAUDIBLE].
You can use the policy call as
the statistics collector policy
data payload and make account
of this specific value.
And this gives us a hash
that's safe but that would I'll
give you a custom report of
how many times this kind of key
will encounter in a
specific [? payroll. ?]
And there may be some
very important information
for different
stakeholders so they
get a sense of the different
kinds of conquerors.
And you can share this
report with operators,
the partners, et cetera.
What I want to do
with this demo now--
go back real quick, and
just kind of close out
with a couple of key things.
So what we did out here was--
I'm still an API
developer, and I'm
looking at my API proxy level.
And although that is a great,
what if, as an API developer,
I forget to use the extension.
And that's a pretty
benign action on my part.
It wasn't intentional,
but the reality
is there are still [INAUDIBLE]
through the API platform.
And you might still be losing
out on some protection,
which we didn't intend to.
So here's another
thing which can quickly
come to your rescue.
So we saw the share flow.
We looked at how
the share flow can
have a set of common policies.
Well, as the administrator or
as the person from the combined
team, I could come out
here and within this use
a feature called flow hook.
So flow hook is a
system-like feature.
So this gives me, as the
administrator, the ability
to say, there are four entry
points into the Apigee API
platform.
So imagine, then, you take
an API proxy [INAUDIBLE]
deployed to an environment,
and [INAUDIBLE] deployment
of this environment for
the purpose of this demo.
So what an administrator
can come and do
is say, at the preproxy level,
before the proxy [INAUDIBLE]
or before I call any target.
So you can pick
which ones, right?
You can click out of
here and actually pick
one of the DLP flows.
And by doing that, whether
the API developer has
used any extension of
policy to protect it or not,
you can come out [INAUDIBLE].
So you have your
business covered
and you are ensuring
that the compliance
policy from a security
perspective is met.
And you can exactly
view the same three
policies in the shared flow.
But one other thing I want
to just touch on real quick
is using a template
based approach.
You now have the ability,
without affecting anything
within the Apigee Edge platform,
you can essentially just
go and update the
template on the DLP side
and change the policy
from that perspective.
So it gives you
[INAUDIBLE] control
on how to really control
sensitive data from leaving
the enterprise.
SCOTT ELLIS: Yeah, that's
a really key point.
I think what you've shown
here is that a key part--
the administrator here can
now through the flow hooks,
apply that across the
entire enterprise.
And let's say you have
another role, which
is your data compliance
administrator that
is different than the
Apigee administrator
and different than
the developer.
They can go in and have
permission to actually change
the data protection policy.
Again that's what
we're looking for,
what we want to protect
against, and that doesn't
have to be done by one person.
It can be separated.
So if your enterprise
has a set of rules,
you can basically do that.
So you get that ease, that
separation and control,
but also just that
accountability that all of this
is happening across
your enterprise.
And I really like the
idea of the flow hooks.
So I think it's just almost
like an easy click and deploy
and you just get the protection.
I think that's really powerful.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Perfect.
So let's summarize this
thing real quick up here.
So what we saw today, what
we covered in the session
today was, we spoke about how
you can use the Apigee Edge API
platform to really
accelerate your API
development by leveraging
the new feature called
Apigee Extensions.
We also showcased how you can
use the data loss prevention
service from Google Cloud to
really protect sensitive data.
The venue enterprises
that are blocking it
from either entering or
leaving those boundaries.
And then we ahead and showcased
two different iterations
of how you can use the specific
data loss prevention template
support from Apigee Extensions
and use that to really secure
PII information.
And then, in the
end, we summarized
how to use advanced
mechanisms like Share Flow
and flow hooks to be able
to secure any kind of breach
of enterprise data and
any kind of sensitive data
leaving the enterprise.
With that I think we will
get into some Q&A. Looks
like there are some questions
which are coming up here.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
both for great content.
We've got a few
great questions here.
Scott, I'll ask this one to you.
We talked about the
various data types,
sensitive data sets that
could be identified masked.
Could you tell us a little bit
about how that process works.
What's the technology
underlying.
SCOTT ELLIS: Yeah, so how are we
identifying these data fields.
And we use a variety
of techniques
for our built-in types.
And so again with the
built-in types are
is when you're configuring
the policy of what you want
to look for, you simply specify
the name or the [INAUDIBLE]
for our [INAUDIBLE]
types, and you
get the power of our detection.
So let's say, for
example, you wanted
to check credit card
numbers, you simply
specify credit card numbers.
And then we employ
different things
like regular expression,
pattern matching,
mathematical checksums,
context analysis, all
depending on the type.
So some types require
us to go in and look
at the context using power
things like natural language
processing and machine
learning to really understand
what that item is.
Other types we can do
really good detection
by simply looking at
the pattern or doing
some mathematical checks.
So it's really a balance
there based on the type.
So we use a variety
of techniques.
Now, outside of
the built-in types,
we have two other ways that you
can extend the power of DLP.
So one, you can go in and
build your own custom types.
And in that case, you
can specify something
like just a regular expression.
Let's say you have
an internal type
and it's pretty well defined
by regular expression,
you can define that
and run that alongside
of our built-in types.
Or you can define it
if it's let's say,
not that well defined.
Maybe it's just a list of
things, a list of words.
We do support some very
powerful word list dictionaries
that can scale up to you
thousands and hundreds
of thousands and
millions of entries,
depending on how you
want to define that.
And those again can be
added into a template
or could be pulled straight from
a more production environment
like you want to just pull it
straight from the cloud storage
or BigQuery table.
And the second part is you can
actually augment all of this.
So let's say you have some
built-in types that you
turn on.
You have some custom
types that you turn on.
But you actually
want to refine that.
I'll give one example.
We use the example here where we
were detecting email addresses.
But let's say that there's
some email addresses you really
don't want to inspect
for or redact.
So one example might be that you
are concerned about user data
but you're not concerned about
employee email addresses.
So you can turn on our
email detector, which
by definition will detect
all email addresses,
and then you can simply do an
exclusion rule where you go in
and say, for emails, exclude
anything that ends in,
let's say, google.com
or anything that
is in this particular list.
Like maybe you don't
want to redact out
support@yourcompany.com
or something like that.
So there's really
powerful things
you can do to extend
the built-in types
but at the core of
how we detect it
against a variety of methods.
And then when you're building
your custom [INAUDIBLE]
exclusion rules, you can use
the power of context, regex,
dictionaries, and
other things to augment
or tune the detection itself.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Thank you, Scott.
I think, Prithpal,
another question for you
is we talked a lot
about the DLP extension.
What are some of the
other extensions that
are used by
customers, and there's
one question about whether we
have any extensions on machine
learning?
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Yes, I think
machine learning is actually
a very new extension
that we just
released a few weeks back
[INAUDIBLE] to the North
and So I think that's kind
of come up quite a bit
when especially our
customers are playing around
with machine learning,
and they want
to be able to do predictions.
That becomes a very
important scenario.
So I have an example.
Let's say you have an API which
is stirring up a lot of data,
and you want to be able to have
followed of that maybe trigger
prediction on some kind
of a model that you built.
So using the Cloud Machine
as a learning engine
extension within the
API proxy editor,
you can use the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine extension
and invoke the
prediction method.
Right, so it's super useful
for any kind of work flow
[INAUDIBLE] get us
out of this ecosystem.
You know you have certain
things you are doing,
and now I want to
run some predictions.
You can easily do
that from there.
I think there's another
follow-up question around what
about the data log extension?
So, let me take
that one as well.
So today we're don't have an
extension of [INAUDIBLE] per se
but if the use case
and the goal is
to be able to actually have
monitoring information being
fed into the data
log, we actually
have a feature within
Apigee Edge called
API monitoring which actually
has [INAUDIBLE] monitoring
for all the API traffic.
We actually are able to
monitor for conditions
such as high latency,
high [INAUDIBLE]..
You can consider
alerts, and those alerts
could be sent through
various notification
channels such as email
or any other system
that has [INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
So , if none of those
options work for you,
you can also have the ability
to use other management API
to extract that monitoring
data and use it for doing any
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, let's see.
I think we may have time for
one more question out here.
The question is,
when you tokenized
sensitive inbound
data, is that mapping
back to the original data
available in some way?
SCOTT ELLIS: So that's
a great question.
So our tokenization
methods today are stateless
and sometimes you might
look at it as faultless.
And what that means
is we're using
secure cryptographic algorithms
to do the tokenization.
And so, basically,
the incoming value
comes in let's say like that
email address, the key that you
specify, which is the
cryptographic key,
those two together
will create that token.
And that's how we can do, again,
repeat the token created again,
but we're not storing a
mapping table or anything
like that on the backend.
And that allows it
to scale, and again
give you the power
of controlling
the access to that key.
But, today, all of those are
going to be based on that.
Now we do provide a
method again that's based
on kind of a, format-preserving
encryption, another method
based on the [? AES ?]
suit algorithm,
as well as an [INAUDIBLE]
cryptographic cache, which
again, that one
is not reversible.
It is a one-way method.
But we can, again, in
our documentation I
think we have a link provided
as part of this that provides
some more detail on that.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Thank you both.
I know we have a
few more questions
that we haven't gotten
to, but I will follow up
with those after the webcast.
And I want to thank all of you
for attending this webcast,
and thank our speakers
for their time.
If you have any further
questions, reach out to us--
Prithpal or Scott.
And then we also have
another webcast coming up
in the next two weeks.
So be sure to keep an
eye out for that one.
Thank you all.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]